American citizen in exchange for an
Afghan tribal leader Bashir nozai was
serving life in a U.S prison on drugs
charges while contractor Mark friedrichs
had been detained in Afghanistan since
early 2020. Heidi Joe Castro reports
my name is Mark ferricks today is 28
November
2021. a proof of Life video published
nearly two years into his captivity
showed Mark freyricks in Afghanistan the
former U.S naval officer and civilian
engineer had been kidnapped by the
Taliban in January 2020 and reportedly
held by the haqqani network now he's
free his return
the culmination of many many months of
tireless
and effective work
why so many colleagues in our government
the Taliban released fireworks in
exchange for [ __ ] Bashir norzai an
Afghan tribal leader who had been
serving a life sentence in the U.S for
opium smuggling norzai was granted
clemency and received a hero's welcome
at the Cabo airport
my exchange I think with God willing can
lead to peace between Afghanistan and
America an American was released and I
am also free with the help of the
Islamic Emirate and mujahadin
in a statement announcing freyrick's
release U.S President Joe Biden made no
mention of the prisoner swap but said
Frederick's Freedom required difficult
decisions to be made
Frederick's sister thanked U.S officials
and said what Biden did was right in
order to save her brother's life
the Trump administration had tried and
failed to secure Frederick's release and
was criticized for not making it a
requirement of the U.S Taliban peace
deal his continued detention remained a
major impediment to improved U.S
Afghanistan relations after the Taliban
takeover last year there was a concern
that after the al-zawahiri's killing in
Kabul apparently there won't be any
contacts between the two sides but this
release indicates that despite the
concerns as I said shared by by the U.S
and the Western Community the U.S is
still in contact with the Taliban and
keeping a sort of engagement at least
one other American remains hostage in
Afghanistan that is filmmaker Iver
Shearer who was detained in Kabul in
August Biden says while there is still
much work to be done on many other cases
the release of freyrix is a
demonstration of the US's commitment to
freeing all hostages abroad Heidi Joe
Castro Al Jazeera Washington
fires island is a professor of political
science at Campbell University he joins
us now live from Kabul a professor
what's your take on this prisoner swap
yeah
Mark's my detention and this swap was
waiting for more than two years while
the shooting Jose has been detained in
New York 2005 so more than a decade a
few years passed almost 17 and a half
years he passed in a federal jail in New
York so this swap was some kind of
milestone for Taliban for
to achieve and for Biden Administration
bringing back Mark who was the last
remaining American citizen in
Afghanistan after the withdrawal of
2021 August 31st was the last
achievement that they should have so
it's a win-win situation for both sides
okay win-win situation but is it going
to pave the way for improved relations
between the US and Afghanistan
uh I really don't think so that it will
somehow undermine those conditions for
bringing the
harmony into the dialogue that the U.S
and uh
holding so far because the condition for
recognizing Afghanistan government the
Taliban amarat islami are very tough to
be achieved by Taliban inclusivity Women
rights girls school
applying or implementing the Doha
agreement and then
somehow waiting for U.S legitimacy
political recognition delisting taking
off the travel ban the sanctions should
we take off these conditions seems very
tough and I think there are so many
other things there is so much to do
regarding bringing some kind of
understanding to the deadlock that has
been so far there
nonetheless the two parties are talking
um that this prisoner swap is uh is the
result of of these ongoing discussions
between the two these these negotiations
that at least has got to be a positive
hasn't it
sure uh you know uh diplomatic uh
struggles usually they uh they somehow
uh uh once they achieve such goals they
somehow celebrate their achievements and
it's uh I think a big achievement for
Biden Administration to bring back Mark
to home and uh for Taliban after 17 and
a half years one of the main supporters
one of their founder but she didn't
reserved to bring them back to uh Kabul
but
the conditions are different from uh
August 15 back when the you know Mark
was detained in 2020 uh there were
conditions different from currently
talibanos were fighting with the U.S and
the U.S troops they were presented in
Kabul and they were supporting the
Republican but now as Taliban took over
the government Taliban are facing a much
more bigger troubles and problem rather
than only a swap of
prisoners they need recognition they
need legitimacy they need the
sanctions the frozen assets to be
unfrozen and they they need to be
integrated into the International
Community Professor what does that mean
then for the prospects of the race of
the final that that last remaining
American prisoner
so I think that these diplomatic talks
they might continue but they might
continue in a different direction
because expectations from International
communities are very high well Taliban
may not be able to deliver those
expected results soon for example the
girl school allowing girls to go to
school we are already in the second air
of power education but Taliban have not
allowed girls to be in school second
year it means we need to wait 2023 or 24
for new education year this year there
is no The Women rights for example the
freedom of speech the inclusivity all
these things were pending and also from
U.S International Community side the
de-listing of the Taliban the travel bin
is there the bounties on some of the
Taliban leadership members are there
they have been not taking those steps
forward so we are still in a deadlock we
hope that there will be some compromise
on these pending issues and we will have
a Way Forward
good to talk to you Professor many
thanks indeed fires Allen there in Kabul